Welcome back everyone this is my boys season
3 trailer video obviously there's a bunch of
new characters and a whole bunch of big twists
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes i will be doing videos for all the
episodes when it releases this summer i'll explain
what's going on with jensen ackle's soldier boy
character he's like a version of captain america
obviously as you can see from all the footage if
you're not familiar with the comic book backstory
but i think the even bigger thing is the fact that
butcher is getting compound v powers so if you're
not familiar with the boys comic book in the
comics huey actually gets compound v power so like
the boys want to even the odds against the seven
so they wind up stealing some compound v giving
it to huey and huey just gets a measure of super
strength that's the only superpower that he gets
so i think the whole idea with season three is
that they're giving butcher a version of that
storyline and the idea is whether or not butcher
is going to turn out to be just as bad as homeland
or when he gets superpowers and that's why they're
giving him superpowers that looks similar to
homelanders only just a little bit different
like the vial of compound v that he's holding
here is green not blue like it usually is so
it's probably some more advanced version of the
compound v formula the two powers that we see
him demonstrating are heat vision like homelanders
in super strength also just like homelanders now
probably not quite as strong as homelander and
his heat vision probably not quite as crazy as
homelanders but as you can see it's meant to be
very close to a version of homelanders level of
power if baby laser eyes could see him now he'd
be so proud the character here with all the guns
and bullets on him that he's beating up like
the one that he super punches is a version of
gunpowder he's meant to be a parody of the
punisher from marvel comics but the idea is
that homelander will still be the most powerful
character on the show that's part of the whole
idea is i think they want to tease that butcher
might be able to do some damage to homelander but
he wouldn't be able to outright kill him i think
they're still saving that for ryan's character i
think ryan is meant to be the only one who will
actually be able to physically kill homelander
you see him losing it just a little bit during the
trailer too homelander style like his eyes sort of
light up like homelanders eyes light up and he
gets ready to rip off that necklace that butcher
gave him that belonged to becca at the end of
season two they basically took him into protective
custody with mallory's group at the end of season
two and they're just gonna be slowly trying to
take care of him and train him to eventually
fight homelanders someday i think depends on how
many seasons the show runs they probably save that
for like the final season of the show but talking
about jensen ackles soldier boy character so it
seems like they're thawing him out of some sort
of deep freeze or cryostasis whatever's going
on here like he has that giant beard but he's
ripping the medical probes off and that breathing
apparatus there's a bunch of scenes of him in a
jungle fighting so that could either be flashbacks
or that could be in present day and he could just
be a p.o.w or because vot always lies about where
they keep their superheroes vot could just be
keeping him in stasis deep in a jungle somewhere
and this could just be the story that they tell
everyone like oh he's been a pow this whole time
that's where he's been as you can see he has a
version of captain america's costume from the
avengers in the marvel movies only it's military
green instead of blue like captain america's
but like the helmet looks exactly like captain
most douchey version of captain america vaught
bills him as the first official superhero like
to give him the actual captain america backstory
he was created by vaught during world war ii
but we know that stormfront was technically the
world's first superhero created by compound bee
soldier boy in the comics was america's first
attempt during world war ii to create a superhero
that happened after stormfront got her powers
the other big change from the comics is that the
original soldier boy wound up dying during world
war ii in the present day of the comic book boys
universe there's another version of the character
who just uses the name meaning he's like captain
america too but it's a totally different version
of the character what they've done on the tv show
is just combined both of those versions and jensen
ackle's character so there's no second version of
the character he is the original and he's just
been in a deep freeze till present day just like
captain america being stuck in the ice during the
first captain america movie the reason why stan
edgar pulls soldier boy out of the fridge so to
speak is to be a counter to homelander stan edgar
is playing four-dimensional chess with homelander
like there's no one actually powerful enough to
kill homelander on earth right now like ryan is
not ready to kill homelander so stan edgar needs
to find ways to control homelander and soldier
boy is just his next version of that soldier
boy's powers are just like captain america's
powers he's not nearly as powerful as homelander
but he's way better at working the crowd like the
people love him more than they love homelander
almost and that's one of homelanders weaknesses
like he's thirsty for everyone's attention that's
the whole way they got him to back off at the end
of season two they still have all that evidence of
him doing all those terrible things that will make
everyone hate him and he can't stand that like he
needs everyone to like him homelander indulging
his fetish by going straight to the source
actually milking a cow this brand new character is
played by laurie holden you'll probably recognize
her from the walking dead earlier seasons
she's playing a version of crimson countess
from the comics who is very clearly a parody of
scarlet witch from the avengers the marvel movies
all this footage of a train is actually from a
music video if you can't tell it's a big parody
of that kylie jenner pepsi ad from a couple years
ago during the protest that was really really tone
deaf pepsi got in a lot of trouble for actually
making it you might remember the commercial like
they tried to say oh you know everybody just chill
out and have a pepsi that'll fix all your problems
so this was going on here during this version
of the music video where he's trying to stop the
protest using his special energy drink the boy
band looking group here might be a version of
the teenage kix which is a group from the comics
that are a parody of the teen titans a train used
to be on their group the character with a star on
his chest is super sonic he's not from the comics
he's a creation on the tv show so he's meant to be
a rival for a train like he'll be a parody of kid
flash or wally west in the way that a train is a
parody of the flash supersonic is also supposed to
be starlight's old boyfriend when she was on the
young americans team they're meant to be a parody
of the young avengers in the comics she had a
relationship with drummer boy when she was on that
team before she joined the seven so super sonic
seems like he's getting that plot from the comics
and he'll just cause some problems for huey when
he comes back into her life and into the limelight
there's a lot of funny ashley moments in this
trailer too like every chance the boys gets they
try to crap on her character to make a family guy
reference she's kind of like the meg of the boys
universe like any chance that any character gets
to yell at her or put her down or do something
terrible to her they take it but it does look like
she finally gets some from pj burns character who
directed their justice league parody movie dawn
of the seven last season girls get it done and it
definitely looks like ashley is getting it done
with him in the bathroom speaking of horny too
there's this funny moment with the deep getting
it on with this woman looking at the octopus
and i think this is just a continuation of that
horny dolphin plot from season one where like the
dolphin was super horny for him trying to get it
on and he was like you know maybe we should get to
know each other first as if he would actually try
to get it on with the dolphin like the whole joke
that aquaman has sex with fish which they actually
just did on peacemaker a little while ago too
i'm so sick of that rumor it's not a rumor
so in this scene it's like the deep is getting
horny by looking at the octopus in the octopus
because he can talk to aquatic life the octopus
is talking dirty to him this brand new character
is a police officer superhero called blue hawk he
might be a version of groundhog who's a version
of wolverine from the comics i think this scene
is frenchy just looking at a bunch of evidence
that they have against vaught covering up the
superheroes killing innocent people this big dance
number with kimiko and frenchie seems like she's
hallucinating or he's hallucinating and they're
inside a mental institution or a hospital of some
kind like it just meant to be a big bollywood
number in someone's head the only thing they don't
really get into during this first teaser trailer
is victoria newman's character remember she's
also secretly a superhero still questionable as
to where her allegiance lies whether or not she's
actually working with stan edgar at vaught because
victoria newman is a version of vic the v from
the comics who was the former ceo of vaught before
stan edgar became ceo she's called vic the veep
in the comics because she is the vice president of
the united states currently so because victoria
newman is running this big political operation
it sounds like she also might be trying to get
into the white house too and it's just the boys
sort of heading in the direction of the comic book
plot where they move to the white house because
vots true goal like stan edgar's true goal is to
control the white house control the government
because that's where true power lies like he can
affect policy he can do whatever he wants create
whatever laws he wants if he can control the
government and in order to do that he just needs
someone inside the white house like the president
the vice president who are sympathetic or working
for him but if you've read the comics there
obviously is a bunch of big twists that happen
at the end of the comic book story i don't think
they're going to be doing most of those or they'll
be doing them in very different ways so the plot
on the boys tv show will be different from the
comic book plot but there are a bunch of easter
eggs like you see a bunch of familiar things here
i will do more videos when we get more trailers
like the next big trailer will tell us more of
the actual story and we'll learn more about what's
going on with soldier boy's character during the
series it will be fun to see jensen ackles play a
superhero and just shake everything up on the show
he's going to cause all kinds of problems for all
kinds of people homelander and the boys alike but
post all your theories in the comments below about
butcher's character once he gets his compound v
powers how crazy do you think he's going to get
because the whole idea in the show is that he's
meant to be just as bad as homelander just in a
different direction like the things that he does
are just as questionable as the things
that homelander does most of the time
so they're meant to be like two sides of the same
coin everyone click here for my brand new obi-wan
kenobi trailer video and the first look at hayden
christensen is darth vader during the episodes
and click here for my brand new marvel moon
night trailer video in avengers easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!